diese neuseeländer führen einen hk auf
zu ehren der verstorbenen queen
nach der todesnachricht ist die trauer
rund um den globus groß die ganze welt
gedenkt der großen monarchen
junge soldaten der neuseeländischen
verteidigungskräfte tanz nahm
kriegsdenkmal in der neuseeländischen
hauptstadt auckland den weltweit
bekannten haka tanz der ureinwohner
ihres landes als zeichen der ehre und
würdigung ihrer königin
denn queen elizabeth die zweite ist als
monarchen nicht nur das staatsoberhaupt
großbritanniens gewesen sondern auch
eben von neuseeland australien und zwölf
weiteren ländern des commonwealth of
nations
[Applaus]